Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt mein name ist tim tritt love.
Und die neunzehnte ausgabe liegt jetzt hier aufm aufm plannungstill und heute geht's mal,
also natürlich wieder um krise weil ist ja krise und ist so wunderbar interessant und wie es so üblich ist für die metaebene muss man da auch ab und zu mal auf die metaebene gehen und dazu habe ich mir den,
frank dazugeholt hallo frank.
Fragen frank rieger wir sind so beide so auch aus diesem ganzen c cosmos entwachsen und,
ist gar nicht so viel zu dir sagen aber du hast dich auf jeden fall solange ich dich begleiten und das ist schon eine weile eigentlich immer immer auf den weltuntergang eingestellt habe ich so den eindruck.
Wie wir gesehen haben zu recht nicht wahr.
Hast du das gefühl jetzt ist es soweit soll als mentaler pepper.
Na ja weiß nicht ob du die die beiden letzten bücher von wem gips kennst,
agency und er hat ja dann ein interessantes konzept vom weltuntergang und es nimmt er den jackpot
der jackpot ist die summe von vielen kleinen katastrophen und problemen
die denn so in ihrer gesamtheit angefangen haben die menschheit fast zu ruinieren
also halt irgendwelche pandemien und klimawandel und meeresspiegel und irgendwie verfall der gesellschaften und
na sozusagen all diese ganzen kleinen probleme die halt wieder mal so haben und die bisher ja noch so in dem bereich waren dass die gesellschaften die hört irgendwie ausstellen konnten werden dann halt in ihrer gesamtheit so groß dass sie halt die steuerungs und migrations kapazitäten der gesellschaften überfordern
ich glaube dieses konzept vom weltuntergang diesen jackpot da hat er,
durchaus eine relativ wahrscheinliche szenario getroffen und irgendwie fühlt es sich gerade so ein bisschen so an so einer am anfang von diesem jackpot stehen.
Weil so viel jetzt zusammenkommt.
Genau also wir haben halt gerne also wenn man so jetzt mal dieses jahr nur betrachtet so was so irgendwie alles irgendwie schon bisher passiert ist und was wir.
Jetzt so auch im zuge dieser dieser corona geschichte als so acht das gibt's ja auch noch.
Irgendwie quasi nur noch aus dem augenwinkel wahrnehmen ja also da
ersaufen hunderte leute im mittelmeer irgendwie bad schandau brennt der wald und eine radioaktive rauchwolke zieht irgendwie nach kiel rüber,
das werden sie unter normalen umständen so die die die top schlagzeilen gewesen und die feiern heute so unter mehr oder minder panorama da ganz hinten.
Ja auch so waldbrand in australien redet auch kein mensch mehr davon dass das war ach das war auch dieses jahr so.
Genau das war auch dieses jahr ja ja genau die menge von dingen die halt dieses jahr schon war nimmt halt irgendwie auch immer weiter zu so also das jetzt irgendwie so wir haben offensichtlich als menschheit diesen planeten mittlerweile so weit
vollständig erschlossen dass er halt auch nur noch sehr wenig raum dafür hat irgendwie unsere faxen und unseren quatsch irgendwie zu kompensieren.
Das stimmt ja ich denke es ist auf jeden fall klar dass wir so von prägt corona und post korona reden werden in der nächsten zeit.
Das ist natürlich jetzt ein einschnitt der ja auch vor allem insofern besonders ist als dass er eben nicht nur so ein land und ein gebiet oder so betrifft sein diesmal sind irgendwie.
Alle länder davon betroffen und es sind auch.
Alle menschen in allen ländern davon betroffen also mir würde jetzt so aus dem stand wirklich relativ wenig einfallen was auf diesem planeten nicht in irgendeiner form direkt unmittelbar oder mindestens unmittelbar betroffen ist.
Ja also eigentlich nur die leute auf der solange sie oben bleiben sind aber die sind ja nicht auf diesem planeten also insofern stimmt.
Ja okay das sind dann also sechs grade.
Oder vielleicht so atom-u-boot e die rechtzeitig losgefahren sind und irgendwie es vermieden haben irgendwo anzulegen oder so.
Ja ja nee also alle anderen müssen irgendwie.
Drüber nachdenken was sind das jetzt eigentlich gerade mit ihnen macht sich vorbereiten oder eben über das jetzt gerade sehen
an der stelle ist es natürlich auch wieder ganz wertvoll für die nachwelt dieses datum zu notieren heute ist der vierzehnte april zwanzig
ja und in dem zu diesem zeitpunkt ist halt europa der ganze westen muss man sagen ist schwer am schwitzen manche länder mehr
italien spanien scheint zumindest jetzt schon mal einen telefonanruf bekommen zu haben wo licht am ende des tunnels angekündigt wird.
Und andere länder.
Und vor allem die usa da ist noch überhaupt nicht absehbar wie krass es werden wird aber es ist auf jeden fall jetzt schon extrem krass.
Interessanteren finde ich gerade so wenn man die also wir haben jetzt angefangen immer von ländern zu reden das hat man auch eine interessante änderung.
Vorher haben wir halt eigentlich eher so von mir so von kontinentalen wirtschaftsräumen geredet so europa oder amerika was denn mir so mexiko kanada usa war oder südamerika oder so wenn man hatte wieso,
globaler entwicklung skizzieren wollte und jetzt reden wir halt immer eigentlich sofort von ländern auch innerhalb von europa und,
wo das darauf hinweist ist dass sich diese.
Abschottung dieses grenzen hochziehen ich meine die grenze zwischen usa und kanada ist geschlossen da muss man sich mal überlegen so die war noch nie geschlossen und.
Also dass diese diese form der integration dies hat lange zeit gab in so extrem hoher geschwindigkeit.
Zumindest für menschen aufgehört hat also wir haben in deutschland jetzt die regel dass jeder der aus dem ausland kommt und länger als glaube zwei oder drei tage nicht in deutschland war muss danach erstmal in die quarantäne.
Das heißt also auch wenn du halt irgendwie nochmal kurz hin nach
holland drüber gefahren ist irgendwie so für zwei drei tage oder so musst du danach in die quarantäne und beim gesundheitsamt bescheid sein keines der länder traut dem anderen land,
das ist der hintergrund davon diese quarantäne regeln die gibt's ja auch überall auch dass sie sich wenn du nach polen fährst oder inzwischen sogar wenn.
Wenn du noch irgendwie drum fährst ja lassen sie sich ja nicht mehr rein zum teilen.
Darfst dich aber nicht mehr aufhalten so die ganzen einzelne landkreise sagen wenn du nicht aus diesem landkreis kommt darfst du dich hier nicht aufhalten so und es hat so ein so ein ding was.
An die beschreibung erinnert von der pest wo es auch so war ne also wo halt die,
die einzelnen städte und einzelnen regionen den anderen nicht getraut haben nachdem so ein bisschen verstanden war dass diese pest durch menschen transportiert wird an den anderen nicht getraut haben dass die diese.
Quarantäne was auch immer eindämmung regeln was ich was ich damals genau hatten einhalten und so ist es jetzt auch zwischen den ländern und es wird halt auch eine ganze weile so bleiben also das hat also die die art und weise wie länder.
Die freizügigkeit zwischen sich wiederherstellen es wird halt richtig kompliziert werden weil es
die müssen einander vertrauen das reporting stimmt also dass die anzahl ihrer reporten fälle hinhaut und dass sie wirklich dann irgendwann
hinreichend niedrige wahrscheinlichkeit haben dass man halt irgendwie sachen also das infektion neu reingetragen werden so wie die chinesen jetzt ja auch sagen so ne wir alle unsere neuen fälle kommen irgendwie von außen so ne also,
gut den chinesen kann man da schnell nichts glauben aber diese diese art wie die länder,
anderen ländern misstrauen und abschotten und sich,
eigentlich nur sich selber oder ihr ihren unmittelbaren nachbarn vertrauen dass ich meine gut deutschland und holland da ist die grenze halt noch offen was einfach daran liegt dass irgendwie rotterdam deutschlands größter hafen ist also wenn sie die grenze zu machst dann,
wird's richtig schwierig so aber die diese dieses misstrauen und diese nicht.
Also dieses momentane nicht anerkennen der maßnahmen der anderen als wirksam das glaube ich so eine der der größten.
Umwälzungen die in extrem schneller zeit passiert sind also wir überlegen uns mal so wir sind im januar.
Was noch völlig unproblematisch möglich einmal quer durch europa zu fahren dass ich in ein auto gesetzt konntest irgendwie keine ahnung in portugal anfangen und irgendwie bis an die polnische ostgrenze fahren ohne ein einziges mal ein pass vorzeigen zu müssen,
aus heutiger sicht quasi unvorstellbar.
Ja wobei mich das jetzt ehrlich gesagt innerhalb von europa auch jetzt nicht.
Also einerseits nicht besonders beunruhigt und auch nicht überrascht weil es ist natürlich auch.
Warum beunruhigt ich das nicht.
Naja weil ich es weil es gewisser hinsicht nachvollziehen kann in dieser situation insofern als dass die lösung für ein problem was so noch nicht da war auf das ich so keiner vorbereitet hat,
natürlich erstmal eine.
Eine eine eine kommunikation erfordert und kommunikation ist halt auf der einen seite sprache die du verstehst,
da haben wir einfach mal mit unseren unterschiedlichen sprachen schon mal eine eine generelle hürde,
zu wissen was gemeint ist du hängst den leuten an den lippen und jedes wort beim fünfmal umgedreht das ist halt in einem mehrsprachigen system wo es keine etablierte meter sprache gibt.
Einfach schwierig ja mal ganz wertfrei und wie wir ja auch gesehen haben grade jetzt im umgang mit,
einleitung der maßnahmen und natürlich dann auch genauso auch wiederum in dem abschwächen der maßnahmen die jetzt teilweise diskutiert werden ist es tatsächlich auch eine kulturelle frage
wie gehst du vor wo sind die befindlichkeiten ja
so eine so eine datenschutz diskussion wie du sie in deutschland hast wirst du wahrscheinlich in vielen anderen
länder so in der form nicht haben da werden dann aber wiederum andere dinge in den vordergrund gestellt und das muss man ja auch alles immer berücksichtigen weil ich denke ein großer wichtiger teil dieser krisenkommunikation ist natürlich auch dieses die leute nicht sinnlos auf die palme bringen.
Damit das ganze handelbar ist und dass dass man an der stelle dann halt sagt okay wir diskutieren das jetzt erstmal in unserem kulturraum bevor wir den nächsten schritt machen und den interkultur raum aufmachen,
ist für mich nachvollziehbar.
Na klar immer nachvollziehbar ist es auf jeden fall was mich daran eigentlich nur interessiert ist halt was es halt so für tiefere instinkte freilegt und was das halt dann für die für die zukunft bedeutet so und dieser instinkt das,
der fremde krankheiten bringt also so dieses dieses ding ist ja eine.
Eine sache die halt auch sich in der in dem verhalten von menschen die eher neos sind also
dem neuen nicht aufgeschlossen sind die dann halt heutzutage auf dem land leben und menschen die ihr neo viel sind in seinem neues doch eigentlich erstmal ganz cool und die halt eher in der stadt leben
was da so ein so ein grundlegender konflikt eigentlich in allen gesellschaften ist also wo du halt irgendwie eine
eher konservative landbevölkerung hast die einem fremden erstmal so ein bisschen skeptisch gegenüberstehen und näher aufgeschlossene stadtbevölkerung die sagt okay irgendwie cool da bringt jemanden neues rezept mit aus vietnam so
und diese diese änderung des mordes der gesellschaft von,
neo viel sozusagen so wir sind
weltaufgeschlossen wir sind national uns interessieren neue sachen wir wollen irgendwie möglichst viel kontakt mit der welt haben weil es uns wirtschaftlich voranbringt und auch kulinarisch und in allen skulpturellen allen aspekten voranbringt hin zu einer,
abschottung zu einem zu einem der fremde ist das problem.
Na sowas ja sozusagen auch so ein gewisser art und weise der kern dieses ausschusses der afd ist das das was man eigentlich sorgen macht weil es in allen ländern gleichzeitig passiert,
überall überall diese sozusagen der dvd not der gesellschaft sich von offen zugeschlossen wandelt und die frage ob wir da rauskommen ist aus meiner sicht nicht beantwortet,
also weil die die die ängste die da jetzt,
kommen die sind halt zum teil auch überhaupt nicht rational aber die funktioniert natürlich trotzdem also die sind mächtig die haben ja eine eine wirkung wie wir uns also ich meine guckt dich an wenn du auf die straße läufst du hältst,
den abstand der fremde ist dir jetzt gerade erst mal irgendwie.
So fremd selbst deine freunde die du wenn du die auf der straße triffst.
Die du sonst umarmen würdest hättest du jetzt halt abstand weil sie sind halt jetzt zumindest eine theoretische risiko quelle geworden.
Na gut man könnte auch sagen man man man nimmt sich aber auch selbst als risiko quelle als potenzielle war und man könntest du also auch mit dem beschützer instinkt beschreiben.
Gegenseitigkeit aber trotzdem ist halt diese dieses.
Diese wandlung von cool da ist jemand neues der kann mir was interessantes erzählen mit dem kann ich in interaktion haben die irgendwie.
Zumindest mal nicht langweilig ist hin zu einem oh gott lass mal lieber irgendwie im videolink unterhalten weil irgendwie so eis essen könnte gefährlich sein.
Na gut aber das tut man dann aber auch noch ne also das ist ja dann sozusagen wenn wenn diese hürde dann nicht mehr besteht
dann dann funktioniert ja die kommunikation auch noch aber ich greife das mal
auf was du sagst und bringst mal auf einen anderen bereich wo sich das tatsächlich ganz interessant zeigten ist nämlich in den usa wo wir jetzt eine ganz interessante sessions bewegung sehen
was man ja eigentlich aus den usa überhaupt nicht kennt man hätte ja jetzt erwartet wenn der obama der präsident ist dann werden wir maßnahmen ergriffen und dann machen die das so so wäre es wahrscheinlich gewesen jetzt allerdings mit dem ober deppen am
am ruder
gibt es ein extrem dissens und halt schon jetzt so deswegen sage ich sitz ession also kalifornien war das oregon und washington also diese ganzen pazifik starten der usa,
beschließen jetzt mal so unter sich wie sie ein eine aufhebung dieser maßnahmen gestalten und koppeln sich von dem föderalen system an der stelle ab.
Obwohl im prinzip ja eine
kulturelle einheit bestehen sollte nur offensichtlich nicht mehr so sehr besteht weil man sich politisch kulturell nicht mehr grün ist.
Na diese zinsbedingungen gibt's ja schon länger ne also das ist ja also ich weiß nicht wann war ich auf dem ersten session dinner in kalifornien gott.
Aber es ist auch an.
Der anderen seite ist es auch so ne also es gibt dann auch noch ein paar andere staaten am da oben message et cetera die haben auch nochmal so eine also das das teilt sich eher nach demokratisch republikanisch auf und ich glaube irgendwo ist auch noch ein republikaner dabei.
Niklas gibt halt irgendwie so ein auf jeden fall so ein so ein so ein ding dabei also insbesondere küsten versus flyer na das ist ja so der das wesentliche ding dabei.
Ich glaube dass das der die spaltung in diese kulturellen einheiten sich anhand dieser corona krise.
Massiv verstärken wird also es gibt ja sogar leute die meinen die usa wird darüber zerbröseln.
Sie werden es nicht bis zu den wahlen durchhalten oder wenn dann nur ganz knapp bis zu den wahlen und dann hängt davon ab wer gewinnt so ob es danach noch eine usa gibt.
Ich bin da mal nicht ganz so pessimistisch weil irgendwie einer der größten fehler die man immer machen kann bei so irgendwie krisen betrachtungen ist irgendwie die regenerationsfähigkeit der usa zu unterschätzen.
Das muss man einfach klar sagen so die sind was irgendwie so ihre fähigkeit sich an den haaren aus dem sumpf zu ziehen angeht.
Das hat schon ein großes land mit vielen leuten die auch irgendwie relativ viel tatkraft haben so also würde ich jetzt noch nicht unbedingt abschreiben so die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es aber schiefgeht ist glaube ich so hoch wie noch nie.
Weil die also wir haben zum einen halt irgendwie die die kleptokratie die jetzt an der regierung sind also,
trump and friends die jetzt halt irgendwie versuchen noch mal den letzten run aus der noten presse irgendwie in ihre eigene tasche zu schicken und halt auch so eher so ein.
So ein endgame ding spielen also das so also alles was die da tun zeugt nicht von der erwartung,
dass es da irgendwie nach ende des jahres noch irgendwie wesentlich weiter geht sondern es fühlt sich alles so an als würden die glauben so bis ende des jahres geht's noch irgendwie und solange müssen sich halt die taschen noch voll machen so.
Mit mit so einer also aus so einer perspektive heraus.
Ist halt eigentlich schon klar dass dann halt einzelne bundesstaaten sagen werden ja so nee tut uns leid wir lassen uns jetzt nicht irgendwie
irgendwie noch ein dreiviertel jahr darauf ein halt irgendwie hier irgendwie von idioten regiert zu werden und gegen unsere interessen zu handeln und.
Könnte durchaus interessant wenn ich meine es gibt in in amiland selber also es wird halt hier nicht so sehr berichtet aber damit menschen redet die da halt irgendwie unterwegs sind also,
ein beispiel ein bekannter von mir der ist aus new york raus.
Und ist zu zu freuen gefahren.
Raus in die berge quasi und er hat halt berichtet dass irgendwie an diversen heiliger exits nicht abfahren konnte.
Weil da die lokalen chefs stehen und nur leute durchlassen die da hinter diesem exit auch wirklich wohnen.
Sozusagen schon so richtige abriegelung die auf quasi eigeninitiative der lokalen sheriffs halt irgendwie passiert.
Wenn du halt irgendwie so eine so eine zustände hast wo quasi dann schon so straßensperren zwischen den county errichtet werden also hat quasi hier so wie hier in meckpomm also wo sie halt ja auch irgendwie keine fremden mehr wollen.
Dann.
Vor dem hintergrund dessen dass also gerade amiland ist ja noch nicht so durchaus ein relativ gut durch bewaffnet das land hat natürlich auch immer gleich so eine dimension die dann halt irgendwie nicht mehr lustig ist oder also.
Ein bekannter der lebt erzählte.
Im im lokalen fernsehen jetzt mehrfach und schon ein bisschen länger von bewaffneten foodwatch groups berichtet wird.
Die weil die polizei in ihre vororte eigentlich quasi nicht mehr kommt also außer als ein mord oder so aber irgendwie so irgendwie diebstahl oder so gehen die halt nicht mehr nach haben die jetzt selber angefangen,
quasi ihre viertel mit bewaffneten streifen zu bewachen und schicken halt auch leute die jetzt nicht sagen können ja ich will hier zu dem und dem und ich habe einen guten grund weil ich muss den essen bringen oder so schicken wir dann halt auch richtig mit vorgehaltener waffe weg,
so das ist halt so also.
Bad.
Also das ist halt schon sag mal so ein so eine also bis max max ist da halt noch ein bisschen aber halt auch deutlich weniger weit als bei uns so.
Ja
Bleiben wir mal kurz bei den bei den usa weil ich glaube oder ich habe mittlerweile so den eindruck dass dass ich diese krise nirgendswo.
Also zumindest nirgendwo im sinne von nirgendwo in der sogenannten zivilisierten welt so nachhaltig niederschlagen wird weil erstmal.
Na so sichtbar also weil vergiss indien nicht also indien indien wird.
So zivilisiert weiß für das falsche das falsche wort das was ist denn die richtige kategorie die first world so ja.
Also alles was.
Industrialisierte länder der ersten.
Genau die durch und ich meine wenn sich irgendjemand für die first world gehalten hat dann ist auf jeden fall die usa ja sie reden wahrscheinlich immer noch
von der nation of earth und erst wenn sie irgendwie alle kurz vorm verrecken sind aber das ist ja sozusagen auch so ein bisschen dieser glaube trotzdem rennen sie ja jetzt.
Wie ins offene messer weil sie eilig durch diese corona krise an ihren verwundbarsten punkten.
Getroffen werden also sie leben von dieser globalisierung wie kein anderes land sie haben das schlechteste gesundheitssystem was eigentlich diesen namen system überhaupt nicht verdient.
Sie haben das am wenigsten gleich verteilt das gesundheitssystem,
na sozusagen in der absoluten leistungsfähigkeit was irgendwie sag mal die die fähigkeit einzelne wohlhabende menschen zu kurieren angeht sind die usa immer noch ungeschlagen weit vorne aber halt nicht in der fähigkeit in für die masse zu behandeln.
Ja nur in dem moment wo sozusagen die kontrolle über diesen virus erlangt werden müsste indem man zum beispiel alle testet behandelt.
Einfach care platziert ist sozusagen die erste reaktion der wirtschaft ist jetzt werden erstmal alle entlassen und ein großteil von diesen,
hat dann sozusagen auch gar keine gesundheitsversorgung mehr weil sie mit dir im job auch ihre,
ohnehin schon viel zu teurer krankenversicherung verlieren was dann dazu führt dass die leute wissen also entweder steige ich jetzt durch den virus hier zuhause oder ich sterbe später durch durch die schulden ist eigentlich jetzt auch egal.
Was natürlich dann dazu führt dass die leute,
sich noch weiter ja weiß ich nicht was was sie dann konkret machen aber auf jeden fall tun sie eben nicht das was jetzt eigentlich geboten wäre.
So das das trifft das land halt dann wirklich schon im mark.
Also ich.
Ich glaube ja dass der grund warum die trump-leute halt so offensiv über aufmachen diskutieren ist dass sie.
Wissen dass sie einen also wirtschaftlich einen sommer sowas wie deutschland hier macht also größere teile der wirtschaft runtergefahren sind nicht allzu lange durchhalten werden,
also weil sie ich meine es gibt ja da nicht mal mechanismen um dafür zu sorgen dass die leute die irgendwie vorige woche noch einen job hatten und heute irgendwie arbeitslos sind und nicht wissen wie sie irgendwie ihre hypothek bezahlen sollen.
Die haben ja keine sicherheitsmechanismen also die haben halt auch keiner in der regel keine reserven also ich meine diese bilder von irgendwie zehntausend also zehntausend autos schlangen bei einer essensausgabe.
Weißt du halt relativ deutlich darauf hin dass dann sehen die resilienz dieser gesellschaft gegen so einen großflächigen ausfall halt irgendwie nahe null ist sondern man sich so anguckt wie die.
Wie damals in der in der in der weltwirtschaftskrise den usa abgegangen ist was dann halt tatsächlich erst mit dem new deal wirklich dann am ende irgendwie so halbwegs wieder eingefangen und beendet wurde,
da sind die mechanismen nur,
mittelmäßig viel besser geworden also es ist halt so sowohl was die gesundheitsversorgung versorgung krankenversicherung aber auch sowas wie arbeitslosenversicherung angeht sondern und das auch,
ein sehr großer unterschied zwischen den einzelnen bundesstaaten die also was die dann halt noch einen einzelnen maßnahmen machen und wie viel geld jetzt ausschütten ob sie heute nochmal irgendwie andere methoden finden um die leute irgendwie wenigstens irgendwie krankenzuversichern und so und,
das team an sich ist aber in seiner gesamtresilienz ziemlich.
Niedrig andererseits ist es halt aber auch extrem dynamisch darf man auch nicht vergessen dass also die,
so schnell wie jetzt die leute da halt irgendwie auf die straße gesetzt wurden so schnell werden die halt auch wieder eingestellt wenn die wirtschaft hat wieder anläuft die große frage ist halt nur läuft die wirtschaft wieder an,
das aus meiner sicht halt irgendwie so eine so eine frage die halt nicht wirklich zu beantworten es war ganz große teile von dem was wir bisher so als wirtschaft betrachtet haben insbesondere in usa ist halt service conny,
das sind halt alles mögliche sachen die mit damit zu tun haben dass menschen
einander begegnen so sei es dass sich die haare schneiden lassen irgendwie die fingernägel machen lassen irgendwie essen gekocht wird die auf veranstaltungen gehen und so weiter also diese dieses ganze.
Nicht selber machen sondern halt an irgendjemand outgesourct haben starbucks und so weiter diese dieses ganze ding da sind ja endlos viele menschen da beschäftigt also der großteil der menschen sogar in den usa und,
wenn du da runter gefahren ist dann ist halt genau dieser großteil der menschen halt ohne lohn und brot und ich hab so den verdacht,
die wissen einfach ziemlich genau dass sie wenn sie das länger als vier wochen machen
dann haben sie wirklich schießereien auf den straßen und plünderungen und müssen nationalgarde einsetzen und so weiter also das ist halt so ein geht halt vielleicht in den wohlhabenderen staaten so die jetzt dann sagen okay wir können 's uns leisten aber so hat in den flyer states wird glaube ich ganz schön schwierig.
Ja und vor allem ich denke da so vor allem an lousiana und so also die linda mit hohem schwarzen anteil et cetera da wird es sich wahrscheinlich noch,
noch eher niederschlagen ich meine die flyer states sind ja eigentlich eher dünn besiedelt und also.
Schwer einzuschätzen sicherlich gilt es überall aber da wohl dichtere besiedelung ist wird das problem noch sehr viel größer sein.
Ja also kann es kann durchaus sein dass das vor allem ich meine du sagst,
klar die sind die sind insofern haben sie immer wieder gezeigt sie können dann auch schnell wieder hochfahren die frage ist nur wie viel prozent von ihrem ganzen system darf ihn wegbrechen,
so dass ein solches hochfahren auch überhaupt möglich ist weil das bedeutet ja jetzt auch.
Viele unternehmen die für andere unternehmen wichtige zu lieferketten etcetera darstellen brechen halt unter umständen komplett weg sind dann halt auch einfach mal pleite die leute sind dann eben auch weg.
Die kriegst du auch nicht wieder so ohne weiteres eingestellt ist ja nicht so dass jetzt drei monate lang zuhause vor sich hin hungern und nur darauf war
denselben job wieder anzunehmen sondern die werden sich dann einfach andere wege suchen und sind eben nicht wieder da das heißt du verlierst halt auch eine ganze menge erfahrung
kompetenz ausbildung etcetera das ist dann halt auch alles weg und das kann eben mal nicht so ohne weiteres wieder aufgebaut werden
und dazu kommen natürlich dann eben auch noch dass das worauf sie eben sonst passieren dass ihn in die welt nämlich zu liefert auch wegfällt.
Na da bin ich tatsächlich noch nicht so ganz am ende des denkens weil was jetzt gerade passiert was wir sehen ist dass die chance aus china.
Erstmal so ein bisschen zusammengebrochen sind und aber jetzt halt wieder anlaufen.
Wir sehen jetzt gerade eigentlich dass china so eine strategie zu fahren scheint zu sagen wir haben es jetzt erstmal soweit runtergedrückt.
Also den die infektionsbad zahlen dass wir damit so ansatzweise leben können auch wenn jetzt wieder ein bisschen hochgehen aber wichtiger ist erstmal dass.
Der dass die wirtschaft wieder anläuft weil sie damit natürlich einen massiven geostrategische vorteil realisieren.
Aber wenn die die einzigen sind die jetzt grade sachen liefern können,
und so sieht's halt gerade momentan aus ne also die die produktion da scheint tatsächlich anzulaufen so und man dauert jetzt hatte ich eine weile bis wieder alles in schwung kommt aber was ich jetzt so sehe also
was es sich so platin fertigung und so zeug also was ich so in meinem beruflichen kontext sehe.
Beginnt halt tatsächlich wieder anzulaufen während es irgendwie überall anders auf der welt halt eher stillsteht so oder weitgehend stillsteht und aus.
Symbolischen betrachtung heraus könnte man sagen je länger du damit wartest wieder anzufahren desto abhängiger wirst du am ende von china sein.
Also das hat schon so eine also dass diese die globalisierung jetzt damit endet und das irgendwie jetzt plötzlich alle anfangen wieder lokale produktion aufzubauen so.
Glaube ich gerade erst mal noch nicht weil
letzten endes ist die die globalisierung von waren und wie die die möglichkeit waren und dienstleistungen durch die gegend zu schicken ist ja irgendwie erstmal nicht geändert.
So klar wenn die grenzen jetzt halt erstmal eine weile rückliger sein und man musste halt ein bisschen objektivieren aber.
Ich bin da noch nicht überzeugt dass jetzt dieser up dazu führt dass,
irgendwie die globalisierung klar die leute werden derzeit erstmal wie ein bisschen mehr lagerkapazitäten aufbauen und just in time so ein bisschen zurückfahren und sagen okay wir
weißt du doch mal den sauren apfel und legen uns mal irgendwie vier wochen irgendwie teile hin irgendwie um unsere produktion weiterzufahren aber
so diese vision von wegen es wird alle produktion wieder lokal und so die sie gerade noch nicht passieren zumal mit dem jährigen ölpreis.
Was china betrifft stimmt das sicherlich also china ist drauf und dran jetzt der gewinner dieser situation zu werden aber
usa lebt ja nicht nur von china ja also allein mexiko wenn ich mir da so gerade die zahlen anschaue die sind also auch noch wunderbar exponentiell unterwegs sie haben zwar noch nicht so hohe zahlen aber wenn die halt jetzt nicht ganz schnell auch massiv runterfahren dann werden die halt
sehr schnell auch noch ein ganz viel stärkeres problem haben weil da hast du natürlich wieder extreme bevölkerungsdichte schlechte versorgung etcetera.
Und na gut also ob china in der lage ist die ganze welt dann zu versorgen,
oder das auch nur ein wünschenswertem und realisierbare zustand ist da bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher.
Gut wünschenswert ist es sicherlich nicht aber die frage ob halt der.
Der zustand dass die.
Werkbank länder also so eine normales okay grob zusammenzufassen sowie mexiko und china und so dass die.
Ist nicht irgendwann wieder auf die reihe bekommen und wir wieder liefern zu können der wird aus meiner sicht nicht anhalten also es halte ich für nahezu ausgeschlossen.
Ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen müßig dass jetzt auch für jedes land so einzeln durchzuchecken zumal eben viel noch nicht wissen aber du hast indien angesprochen
das ist sicherlich ein ganz gutes beispiel dafür wo einfach noch so die ein oder andere zeitbombe tickt
generell alle extrem bevölkerungsreichen länder die dicht besiedelt sind bangladesch ist da sicherlich auch noch mal ein beispiel.
Das wird natürlich dann auch schon nochmal zu einem massiven ausfall in dieser ganzen globalisierung kette führen.
Ja das kann durchaus sein dass es für eine weile halt irgendwie nicht nicht gut.
Bei vielen produkten funktioniert so also man man sieht es ja schon so wenn man halt auch nach bestimmten sachen sucht bei amazon oder so dann findet man halt,
nicht mehr so viel aber wenn man dann zum beispiel wieder auf ebay geht,
wo hat ja viele von den china seller mittlerweile unterwegs sind weil amazon ja gesagt hat wir restaurant nur noch sachen die halt jetzt wirklich zwingend notwendig sind weil ich ihn jetzt gerade auf ebay und aliexpress aus,
und da kriegst du dann halt eben wirklich fast alles wieder also die chinesen.
Die fackeln da nicht lange die lieferzeiten sind zwar ein bisschen länger geworden aber.
Es gibt ja sogar wieder textil sicherungen aus china und sonne weil halt bangladesch anfängt auszufallen und so also ich.
Ich denke dass diese überlegung halt irgendwie wenn man jetzt irgendwie noch richtig lange wartet mit irgendwie zumindest die produzierende wirtschaft wieder anfahren,
dass man dann massiv ins hintertreffen gerät dass die auch die deutsche diskussion stark bestimmt also wir haben ja momentan dieses problem dass die autoindustrie ja,
quasi aus ist was unter anderem auch damit zu tun hat dass.
Zu müssen vielen bundesländern was nicht in allen der neuwagen-verkauf ja auch nicht stattfindet.
Also die die autowerkstätten dürfen glaube ich gerade keine keine neuwagen verkaufen sondern nur noch reparieren.
Kann sein.
Was das halt dazu führt dass die die,
produktion bei den autofirmen halt im wesentlichen stillsteht weil natürlich auch so langsam deren deren abstellplätze voll sind,
da hängt er in deutschland dann halt einfach mal so keine ahnung also wie bestimmt fünfzehn oder zwanzig prozent der wirtschaft dran mit irgendwie allen folge geschichten die da hinten dran sind so ne also alle zulieferer und so weiter und.
Das jetzt irgendwie angefangen wird zu sagen so ja wir brauchen jetzt natürlich sofort nachdem wieder anlaufen erstmal eine neuwagenprämie
ist halt auch genau diese furcht zone also der dass du das jetzt gewesen sein könnte oder also das hat wie man sagt ok ja auto kaufen herrgott also warum sollte ich jetzt ein auto kaufen eigentlich ne.
Wo sollte man damit schon hinfahren.
Genau kannst du eh nicht irgendwohin fahren die karre georgie auf der straße steht die kann sowieso noch eine weile rostendes jetzt irgendwie nicht so problematisch also ja.
Ich glaube das ist das ding was deutschland hat richtig hart erwischen wird also das diese umstellung auf elektroauto wo irgendwie alle mal gesagt haben ja gibt's ja bestimmt hundertfünfzigtausend arbeitslose und so.
Zurzeit kindergarten gewesen sein im vergleich zu dem was jetzt passiert wo die leute einfach merken okay so auto kaufen na ja muss ich ja auch nicht unbedingt ne.
Das wird sich auch noch eine weile hinziehen also weil in dem augenblick wo ich nicht mal an die ostsee fahren kann wie er gerade ist.
Wer kann denn momentan als berliner habe ich keine möglichkeit irgendwo an die ostsee zu fahren legal kann nicht nach polen an die ostsee fahren ich kann nicht nach ostsee fahren ich kann nicht nach westdeutschland fahren.
Dann auch kein auto
und dann hast du halt irgendwie also außer du fährst jetzt damit zur arbeit aber arbeiten sind halt auch weitgehend geradeaus für viele so und daraus hast du halt irgendwie einen einen bedarfs einbruch wo ich nicht sicher bin dass ich die.
Deutsche gesamtwirtschaft davon so schnell erholen wird.
Und da ist der tourismus noch überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt.
Von dem andere länder sicherlich noch mehr abhängen aber mecklenburg-vorpommern ist schon lustig dass die irgendwie zu machen obwohl sie im wesentlichen von tourismus leben also lustig ist das natürlich nicht aber es ist halt bezeichnen.
Die haben halt ne die haben halt einfach massiver angst dass sie wenn sie da größere mengen touristen am start haben mit denen nicht klarkommen wenn die krank werden.
Die krankenhaus kapazitäten in diesen ländern sind ja auf die einwohner nicht die touristen ausgelegt.
Das ist halt der grund warum die dann sagen so naja nee wir wollen nicht mal irgendwie die leute die ja eigentlich ein ein haus mit einer zweitwohnung haben irgendwie hier am start haben sondern halt irgendwie eigentlich nur die leute für die wir halt hier auch krankenhaus kapazität am start haben.
Das hat so eine logik wo man sagen muss nachvollziehbar ist halt nur blöd wenn man eigentlich keine angst mehr möchte sondern.
Also diese diese verschiebung der macht ich meine das ist das ist vielleicht schwer vorhersagbar gerade noch wie weit sich das alles so entwickelt aber ich glaube es lässt sich festhalten findet statt.
China ist auf jeden fall da ein potenzieller profiteur und ich denke dass auch diese.
Totale handlungsschritte die die usa auch da zeigt nochmal ein weiteres mal zu einer erheblichen abwertung der position dieses landes führen wird.
Es kann auch nochmal richtig krass werden ja also wenn man es jetzt angucken so die instrumente der macht der usa.
Mit dem sie halt irgendwie ihre jan machtanspruch weltweit halt produziert nämlich die jusos navi.
Die sind halt de facto aus die haben jetzt irgendwie corona auf irgendwie vier flugzeugträger und wahrscheinlich auf allen anderen auch noch sie haben's noch nicht gefunden.
So und da wird natürlich dann irgendwann auch so eine frage wo leute die halt sagen so wie china zum beispiel
wir haben das jetzt bei uns so einigermaßen im griff und irgendwie videos navi ist halt irgendwie gerade irgendwie damit beschäftigt irgendwie zu überlegen ob sie irgendwie gerade mal wieder rausfahren will solange sie nicht weiß dass ihre sie leute halt corona frei sind,
da kann man halt schon mal auf ideen kommen so ne also ich meine als taiwan würde ich mir gerade echt sorgen.
Ja in der tat.
Und und wir sind jetzt halt in der interessanten situation.
Wobei interessant halt eher im sinne der chinesischen fluges zu betrachten ist dass die.
Die art und weise und der verlauf der epidemie in den einzelnen ländern und muss man auch sagen in den in den den regionen.
Einen massiven einfluss darauf haben wird wie die machtposition der einzelnen länder danach ist und zwar nicht nur der absolute verlauf so nach der zeitliche verlauf also wie schnell.
Werden sie in der lage sein wieder handlungsfähig zu sein und sich mit irgendwelchen anderen dingen zu beschäftigen als jetzt irgendwie solche bekämpfung
so wie schnell werden die zum beispiel auch in der lage sein halt irgendwie eine ihre armee zu benutzen sondern es gibt halt genügend länder bei denen die die grenzkontrolle gerade mehr der männer nur eingefroren sind.
Weil beide seiten,
einigermaßen gleich stark sind und man halt irgendwie so militär-strategische irgendwie jetzt sich nicht unbedingt irgendwie einen großen gewinn davon erhofft jetzt halt irgendwie dazu handeln so wenn jetzt aber also nehmen wir mal fiktives beispiel.
Nehmen wir zum beispiel bei indien pakistan also nehmen wir mal an irgendwie eins von den beiden ländern schafft es halt irgendwie mit dieser solche massiv viel besser umzugehen und die sehr viel schneller in den griff zu bekommen und sehr viel weniger
disruption des öffentlichen lebens und der wirtschaft zu haben und sehr viel schneller in der lage zu sein seine armee wieder zu benutzen so.
Kann das natürlich schon auf den gedanken kommen mal zu gucken irgendwie wie schwach der nachbar denn eigentlich grade wirklich so ist da sind und davon gibt's
viele so eine konflikte ist jetzt irgendwie in der pakistan ist eher unwahrscheinlich weil bei der atomwaffen haben.
Syrienkonflikt ist natürlich jetzt damit auch nochmal neu aufgewirbelt.
Türkei russland sind ja da auch alle grade irgendwie aktiv serien etcetera keine ahnung wie es da jetzt ehrlich gesagt bei den einzelnen ländern gerade aussieht aber sorgen haben die alle gerade.
Klar oder keine ahnung wenn irgendwie die ukraine zum beispiel bei sich irgendwie besser in den griff bekommt als die russen dann könnten die schon auf die idee kommen zu sagen okay wir holen uns mal also versucht mal diesen donalds konflikt da irgendwie.
Die krim wieder zurück.
Oder wollen uns die krim wieder zurück na das sind halt so sachen die durchaus passieren können also die sollte man jetzt nicht irgendwie als das wird schon nicht passieren weg buchen sondern was ich halt so beobachte ist das.
Bei so den den leuten die jetzt gerade in einer führungsposition in vielen ländern sind die sind halt eher so ein bisschen.
Sag mal weniger zögerlich um es mal irgendwie neutral zu formulieren na sowas halt irgendwie die die saudis zum beispiel machen so also dieser saarländer der jetzt gerade da der der de facto chef ist,
der ist halt,
durchaus willens halt irgendwie sich dein abenteuer zu stürzen so und libyen zum beispiel ist auch gerade irgendwie so ein so ein konflikt wo alle ihre modernen waffensysteme ausprobieren und zwar ohne dass irgendjemand groß hinguckt und die prügeln sich da halt
so richtig irgendwie und führen da halt also richtig krieg irgendwie mit modernsten mitteln und heißt,
nicht dass ich halt solche konflikte dann,
für ewig einfrieren werden also was jetzt gerade passiert ist dass die alle es gibt halt mehr der männer sind weltweit ein waffenstillstand bis auf wie gesagt libyen zum beispiel.
Hatte die bürger auf ihre angezettelt dass sie gesagt haben ja wir versuchen mal irgendwie überall waffenstillstand durchzudrücken damit alle sich erstmal um die krise kümmern können aber das wird halt irgendwann enden und dann wird halt die frage sein wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich schneller fertig geworden damit
und wer hat dann irgendwie seine militärischen und und geheimdienstlichen fähigkeiten schneller wieder am start so und.
Da bin ich nicht so sicher dass das halt überall gut geht im gegenteil ich bin ich relativ sicher dass es irgendwo schief geht wird die frage ist halt nur wo also zum beispiel in china südchinesischen meer
also die amerikaner sind da bisher halt immer mit ihren mit der jusos navy durch geschippert und auf navigation operations um halt den chinesen zu verdeutlichen dass diese inseln diese da haben
jetzt zwei inseln sind aber sie trotzdem niemand daran hindern können dadurch zu fahren.
Ob das jetzt in zukunft immer noch so sein wird wird man halt sehen sondern das ist jetzt so ein ist halt eher so eine situation wo halt die die karten halt neu gemischt werden so und niemand kann so richtig vorhersehen in welche richtung außer dass die wahrscheinlichkeit dass,
wenn china ist nicht versemmelt und von der zweiten welle erwischt wird dass die am ende so als netto gewinner rausgehen relativ wahrscheinlich ist.
Und ich meine wir haben so einen moment ja im prinzip schon mal gehabt das war ja genau die übernahme der krim.
Ja wo die russen einfach so eine überlegenheit hatten die ukraine entsprechend geschwächt war und usa europa sich alle nicht nennenswert einig waren ich meine gab es jetzt noch keinen virus problematik insofern
war das schon zu normalen zeiten aber dann war das halt einfach so einfach eingeritten haben gesagt soja krim also es war schon immer unser.
War schon immer unser badewanne genau.
Genau so und jetzt ist es einfach so und alle so ja aber okay ja.
Gar nicht so einfach hier optimistische perspektiven zu eröffnen.
Gerade gerade optimismus ist gerade so ein bisschen schwierig so also es ist halt irgendwie.
Schwierig genau.
Also nicht so nicht so easy.
Aber man muss ja dann auch mal einfach mal gucken wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus was ja ist auch so ein bisschen in frage steht.
Und frage gestellt wird ist natürlich so kapitalismus an sich ist das eigentlich so eine gute idee oder ich würde mal sagen vielleicht weniger so kapitalismus
eben einfach mal so dieses total davon galoppierende globale system und dieser raubbau auch an der welt das soll so ein kleiner nebenkriegsschauplatz ist ja auch.
Was wir jetzt gerade erleben und ich muss sagen vorbehaltlich.
Weitere erkenntnisse aber so stellt es sich mir zumindest derzeit da dieser virus ist.
Eine gewisse wahrscheinlichkeit ein virus der in fledermäusen entstanden ist.
Und auf irgendeinem weg nicht unbedingt direkt vielleicht direkt vielleicht aber auch über den umweg über andere tiere auf den menschen übergesprungen.
Und das hat eben auch einfach viel damit zu tun dass tiere wenig rückzugsräume haben weil,
den tieren halt dieser raum einfach genommen wird durch besiedlung durch landwirtschaft durch abbau von von wäldern dschungel und und allem möglichen.
Das ist dann sozusagen so 'ne so 'ne folge davon wo man sagen kann naja müsste man sich auch schon mal darüber gedanken machen ob wir da jetzt nicht so zeigen an unsere grenzen kommen,
also wann kommt der nächste virus so jetzt selbst selbst wenn wir diese aktuelle kurve neunzehn geschichte jetzt durch
irgendein wunder schnell in griff kriegen ja was weiß ich warum kumpel gates und sagst du ach übrigens ja gleich erster treffer hat gesessen und so dauert jetzt noch ein halbes jahr dann,
läuft der hase wird nicht so kommen aber optimistischen szenario dann sagt uns ja keiner dass wir nicht in den nächsten fünf jahren schon wieder an derselben stelle stehen.
Wir werden an derselben stelle stehen wenn er sich da nicht relativ.
Deutlich was ändert ich fürchte halt nur was sich ändern wird es weniger unser umgang mit der natur.
Weil dazu sind wir einfach mittlerweile auch zu viele menschen,
und die zu viele menschen die halt einfach noch den traum vom wohlstand halt noch nicht zu ende geträumt haben,
das heißt.
Wird sich vermutlich nicht ändern sondern meine perspektive darauf dass ich eher sag mal die selbstverständlichkeit von antipasti emie maßnahmen.
Ja ja verstärken wird also dass man halt irgendwie keine ahnung sowas wie ein globalen impfausweis hat oder zu besten europäischen impfausweis der halt
bestandteil des passes ist und da wird dann halt auch noch gleich eingetragen gegen welche wie der letztjährigen pandemien man jetzt im monat
oder ob man wenn man dann halt irgendwie zufällig einen universellen antiviralen impfstoff findet ob man den dann bekommen hat dann wird
sicherlich eine menge so quarantäne regeln geben wenn man versucht zu reisen aber tatsächlich die.
Zumal die ausbeutung des planeten im zuge der globalisierung von irgendwie waren und dienstleistungen.
Hab ich jetzt schwierigkeiten zu sehen wie dieser virus die beenden wird sondern im gegenteil es wird dann wahrscheinlich eher so ein
wettrennen darum geben irgendwie die jetzt im nächsten jahr ausgefallene rendite haltung wieder reinzuholen so also so denken die,
es gibt natürlich auch positive hoffnungsvolle zeichen so dass irgendwie erste landarzt drüber nachdenken doch mal bedingungslos grund ein grundeinkommen einzuführen um halt dafür zu sorgen dass man halt insgesamt als gesellschaft resilient der gegen solche verwerfungen wird
wiederum andererseits ist aber auch sag mal einen ein hoher staatsanwalt teil an der wirtschaft,
führt halt nur dazu dass die,
interessen von großkonzernen staaten noch weiter zusammenlaufen also was wir da haben ist halt ein trend den es ohnehin schon gibt das also große konzerne und staat entdecken dass sie im wesentlichen halt dieselben interessen haben.
Und wenn jetzt der staat dann auch noch anteilseigner an diesen großkonzern wird dann entsteht da so eine form von kapitalismus die einerseits
dem einzelnen noch weniger persönliche freiheiten gibt weil irgendwie statt für großkonzerne sich eigentlich sind das immer schön überwacht werden soll und andererseits aber weniger handlungsmöglichkeiten,
weil viele geschäftsfelder halt einfach schlicht und ergreifend nicht mehr beackert sind weil es da halt staatlich unterstützte großkonzerne gibt was wir jetzt halt schon sehen halt so dieses
die regeln mit denen halt in deutschland halt irgendwie corona hilfe ausgeschüttet wird weisen halt relativ klar in so eine richtung dass halt irgendwie da
die leute die jetzt da an der macht sind halt sich eher so ein vw modell vorstellen also wo der staat immer fünfundzwanzig prozent irgendwie an den konzernen hat und
wenn halt irgendwie der konzern meine gesetzesänderung braucht dann hat der staat halt irgendwie auch ein finanzielles eigene interesse daran diese gesetzesänderung durchzudrücken und dann
haben wir halt so einen effekte hat heißt im englischen heißt der regulatorik capture also die,
sozusagen die gefangennahme der regierungsfähigkeit des staates für die finanziellen interessen der großkonzerne und ich glaube.
Ist wahrscheinlich eher etwas dabei hinten rauskommt und nicht zwei mal 'ne freundliche soziale marktwirtschaft die,
dafür sorgt dass alle irgendwie machen können und irgendwie eine hinreichende soziale absicherung haben also wir wollten eigentlich optimistische sagen.
Wir bleiben erstmal unsere these treu und haut erstmal was raus stammung cup fällt mir dabei ne das ist doch,
ist das nicht der begriff staatsmodell populistischer kapitalismus guter alter ostsee ostsee kampf begriff.
Na wir sehen uns aber jetzt ne also das hat jetzt gerade in den usa mit mit der art und weise wie der halt irgendwie die die korona hilfe von zweitausend milliarden muss man sich ja mal wieder vergegenwärtigen.
Die halt irgendwie im wesentlichen an die die großkonzerne die rechtzeitig an trump gespendet haben gehen und auch in deutschland ist es ja so ne also es ist halt so wenn man in deutschland halt irgendwie.
Mehr als zweihundertfünfzig mitarbeiter hast bist du in einer völlig anderen klasse von irgendwie möglichkeiten für corona hilfe als wenn du zehn mitarbeiter hast so
und wenn du fünftausend mitarbeiter hast nochmal in einer ganz anderen klasse und so weiter das heißt also diese konzentration hin zu größeren einheiten weil,
der staat natürlich lieber sag mal mit mehr arbeitsplätzen redet in form von möglichst wenigen vertretern.
Diese idee hat okay wenn ich irgendwie einen betriebsrat habe der fünfzigtausend arbeiter vertritt ist einfacher mit ihm zu reden als irgendwie mit tausend betriebsräten jeweils fünfzig arbeiter vertreten.
Ja vollständig nachvollziehbar so und da verwaltungs- gesichtspunkten aber bedeutet eben auch dass daraus halt so ein naja so ein,
so ein konglomerat ding entsteht was halt irgendwie nicht wo also staat und große unternehmen immer schwieriger auseinanderzuhalten werden und damit natürlich auch die bürgerrechte in gefahr geraten weil wenn der staat ist dann als seine aufgabe sieht die,
großkonzern am laufen zu halten an denen ihr eine beteiligung hat.
Dann werden die entsprechenden gesetze auch so gemacht werden sei es jetzt irgendwie für datenschutz oder das andere individuelle freiheiten so.
Ja das ist ja auch so also ich hatte ein interview gesehen das war ganz interessant es ging irgendwie auf twitter auch ordentlich rum wo man darauf hingewiesen wurde na ja dass man,
dass dieses retten von großen unternehmen insofern auch ein fehler darstellen kann oder darstellt.
Weil ja letzten endes.
Ein unternehmen insolvenz zu bringen ja nicht unbedingt immer gleichbedeutend ist mit der auflösung dieses unternehmens das heißt ja dass er sozusagen erstmal die leute die da ihr geld drin haben und das sind dann einfach in der regel halt große anteilseigner,
private besitzer hedgefonds etcetera das die erstmal ihr geld verlieren ja weil sie dann halt zahlen müssen.
Was eigentlich auch mal gerecht wäre weil er sonst immer der schaden eines einer solchen krise letzten endes immer bei den.
Angestellten und den leuten die sowieso nie viel davon gesehen haben ankommt.
Also muss musst du natürlich ein bisschen differenzieren es gibt durchaus eine menge leute die,
über fonds oder rentenversicherung und so weiter an diesem unternehmen auch beteiligt sind die jetzt nicht groß investments buden sind also da muss man schon sich auch ein bisschen genauer angucken.
Falls es möglich ist nicht immer möglich wie halt die.
Sag mal struktur der leute der leiden oder profitieren ist würde ich halt nicht nicht unbedingt über einen kamm scheren da gibt es sehr sehr unterschiedliche strukturen.
Aber die anteile von privaten leuten sind sehr sehr sehr sehr gering im vergleich zum rest.
Hängt vom unternehmen ab,
es ist halt so es gibt halt unternehmen die haben eine sehr breite aktien streuung es gibt unternehmen die haben eine sehr geringe aktien streuung ist auch immer abhängig davon wie sich dieses unternehmen positionieren aber,
ich glaube der das hauptproblem ist dabei dass in dem augenblick wo dein unternehmen in die insolvenz gehen lässt.
Stehen da halt zu firmen wie blackrock und co die solche ruinen dann halt einfach aufkaufen.
Und dann hast du halt irgendwie gar nichts mehr also das hat so eine also die frage wie man als staat da sinnvolle wirtschaftspolitik macht.
Glaube ich auch noch nicht so gut beantwortet also so ein zu sagen okay man kauft sich da rein als staat um eine feindliche übernahme zu verhindern.
Ist vielleicht jetzt auch nicht die allerblödesten idee dazu also unter erhalt der gesamte von wirtschaft gesehen nur muss man halt sicherstellen dass.
Die fehler die man halt mit der treuhand gemacht hat nicht nochmal gemacht werden was fast unmöglich ist und vor allen dingen sicherstellen dass,
der staat dann eben nicht zum erfüllungsgehilfen dieser konzerne wird weil er eben dann daran auch beteiligt ist.
Welche fehler der treuhand meist so.
Die was da halt an selbstbindung passiert ist also hat eine menge unternehmen,
die chance benutzt haben konkurrenten weg zu konsolidieren also das sind es gibt ja durchaus auch diesen vorschlag zu sagen man benutzt jetzt die gelegenheit um mit staatlicher hilfe große,
sag mal european oder german champions zu schaffen also indem man halt einfach firmen die in denselben bereich unterwegs sind mit staatlicher hilfe konsolidiert zu
größeren einheiten zu größeren konzernen
und bei dieser gelegenheit gibt's natürlich jede menge selbstbedienung möglichkeiten für leute die sich dann halt irgendwie entsprechend raus kaufen lassen.
Da hängt dann immer sehr von den details ab aber das ist halt so eine so eine frage die glaube ich auch sehr darüber.
Entscheiden wird wie erfolgreich starten aus dieser krise rauskommen und,
mein bauchgefühl momentan ist das staaten die noch eine produktionskapazitäten haben also wo noch nicht so geringer teil der wirtschaft tatsächlich produzieren und nicht dienstleistung ist,
eher besser dabei rauskommen.
Weil der bedarf nach dienstleistungen wird glaube ich eher fallen weil irgendwie digitalisierung,
bedeutet halt in der regel dass mehr sachen halt eben nicht mehr durch menschen passieren oder nur noch sehr mittelbar durch menschen passieren oder diese menschen einen sehr großen automatisierungs haben,
daraus folgt dann wiederum dass der also mal die anzahl an arbeitsplätzen in der service-akademie,
wird wahrscheinlich am ende geringer sein wird dann wahrscheinlich irgendwann wieder steigen aber wird tendenziell eher geringer sein dann gibt es natürlich dieses ganze problem mit dem sommer alles das publikum ist ne also wir haben ja viele industrien.
Bei denen sich sondern der verkauf von produkten also der musikindustrie oder filmindustrie wo sich der verkauf von produkten,
weg gewandelt hat hin zu einem viel stärkeren live-meeting
sondern halt irgendwie an guckst du die allermeisten musiker die halt irgendwie davon leben leben halt von ihrem live-konzerten also von von den verkäufen auf den den streaming-plattformen gar tonträger ist halt,
nur ein relativ kleiner teil ihres ihrer einnahmen selbiges bei irgendwie comedians oder irgendwelchen anderen leuten die oder buchautoren also die viele buchautoren die
versuchen vom bücherschreiben zu leben leben de facto nicht von den verkaufszahlen ihrer bücher sondern halt von den lesungen
und das das bricht ja alles weg ist alles alles erledigt gerade so und online ist da natürlich auch nur ein relativ unvollkommen substitutes für
und dieser,
was mit diesem ganzen teil der wirtschaft passiert ist halt vor kaum unklar also wann wann der wieder anlaufen kann ob der dann in dem umfang gehabt wieder anläuft ob die leute danach überhaupt genügend verfügbares einkommen haben.
Was sie für irgendwie unterhaltung und spaß und spiel ausgeben wollen,
oder ob sie dann sagen ja nee keine ahnung hat jetzt einfach eine ganze weile mit der krise und wir lassen die war erstmal die kohle irgendwie auf der bank oder kaufen lieber halt noch irgendwie parolen klopapier als anlage oder so.
Gesichtsmasken.
Genau gesichtsmasken ja.
Ja klar also das da gibt's natürlich eine ganze reihe also theater die zum beispiel sozusagen noch überhaupt gar keine digital option für sich entdeckt haben.
Na da gibt's schon,
da gibt's schon was und da passiert jetzt auch gerade einiges so wo sie halt versuchen irgendwie neue formen zu entwickeln sind die noch relativ weit hinter der kurve dabei.
Hätte auch schon früher mit anfangen können ne also es ist schon so eigentlich der bereich der mir so einfallen würde der ist extrem avers ne aber wo es natürlich klar ist es also alles was wirklich auch einfach auf real life basiert ne also messen veranstaltungszentren
bars partys clubs das ist.
Das wird wahrscheinlich recht recht bitter werden und da trifft es natürlich,
nur die kleinen jetzt sind wir von von von ganz großen vom stamm cup wirklich zur eckkneipe gekommen die auswirkungen sind.
Hängt ja leider zusammen.
Ja ja leider.
Weil weil du hast die eckkneipe wird halt nicht irgendwie von einem großkonzern mit staatlicher beteiligung sondern halt von leuten die unseren freunden von den pion betrieben die gerade irgendwie echt knabbern und deswegen nach spenden fragen also das halt irgendwie so ein,
sag mal so alles was halt vielfalt ist und irgendwie kreativität und
dinge die jetzt halt nicht irgendwie so macdonald's irgendwie einheits pumpe raus stampfen sind dafür sind großkonzerne halt einfach schlicht nicht geeignet so und das halt irgendwie deswegen halt das leben in einer welt die halt von so
konzern dann auch noch mit staatliche unterstützung beherrscht wird.
Finde ich halt jetzt halt auch nicht so besonders attraktiv so deswegen ist die frage wie man halt irgendwie so einmal dieses leben im kleinen und diese vielfalt im kleinen noch kommerziell wieder auf die reihe bekommt für mich schon ziemlich wichtig so.
Ja da muss auf jeden fall was getan werden.
Was ist denn so dein take auf die hochfahren raus aus der raus aus der aus dem runterfahren modus.
Frage also naja.
Naja also man ist halt relativ klar dass das einzige was hat funktioniert sind halt masken also das ist halt so ein die,
wir haben halt irgendwie gesehen dass der.
Die leute wenn du halt ein supermarkt guckst selbst da kriegen sie es mit diesen abstandsregelung nicht hin abgesehen davon wissen wir mittlerweile dass die abstände sowieso viel zu klein sind also wenn er halt guckst dass irgendwie einen intensiv joggen,
hat halt irgendwie eine zwanzig meter schlappe hinter sich,
es ist halt schon also weißt du der einzige weg raus werden halt masken sein so das hat
offensichtlich und klar und so meine stille hoffnung dass er viele von diesen
maschinen mit den masken gebaut wird also insbesondere mit denen es fließt gemacht wird aus denen diese masken gemacht werden kommen ja von deutschen unternehmen und
ich hoffe einfach dass vor vier wochen oder so irgendjemand da mit dem geld drauf auf dem hof stand sagt guten tag mein name ist müller ich komme aus dem kanzleramt und ich würde gerne ihre produktion aufkaufen bauen sie bitte da drüben die turnhalle auf.
Also melitta melitta hat ja schon angekündigt dass sie jetzt voll in die masken produktion einsteigen werden und ihr erster ihr erster wurf war da noch tatsächlich ja wir nehmen dann auch erstmal hier die form unserer filtertüte also es ist nicht dieselbe
stoff aber es ist tatsächlich einfach melitta filtertüte mit mit clip,
das ist sozusagen das erste produkt was sie jetzt sofort produzieren können und auch produzieren und im nächsten schritt haben sie gesagt wird es da ein bisschen.
Sieht man vielleicht ein bisschen besser aus.
Naja ich weiß also das ist halt also das ist eine stille hoffnung ist aber so deutschland braucht immer so eine weile bis es nie kennen gekommen also egal ob jetzt irgendwie
überschwemmung oder irgendwie sonst irgendwas so es braucht halt immer so eine weile bis halt so die sich total zurecht gerüttelt hat aber dann exportieren wir halt.
Wenn der dampfer erstmal fährt dann dann hat er auch schub.
Genauso wenn egal ob's jetzt irgendwie gesichtsmasken oder panzer sind wenn die produktion halt einmal rollt und rollt sie halt so und das ist halt so ein so eine gewisse hoffnung so dass deutschland in dem punkt.
Da halt irgendwie jetzt ein bisschen besser dasteht als vielleicht der rest der welt meine vermutung.
Oder auch den rest der welt auch helfen kann also es geht ja.
Beliefern kann genau ja.
Uns weil wir sind ja auch nichts ohne den rest.
Nur also daraus resultiert wiederum natürlich in dem augenblick wo wir halt in der lage sind halt den kran zu liefern hat die wirtschaft hier natürlich auch wieder was zu tun und so weiter also das ist ja so ein also meine vermutung ist dass die.
Tatsächlich verfügbare inländische produktionskapazitäten von masken den ausschlag dafür geben wird wann der lok darin aufgehoben wird.
Also das hat weil dieses ganze diskussion mit schulen oder nicht schulen und grundschulen auf oder nicht oder auf und so weiter.
Ist halt eigentlich nur eine seite show so also das wichtige ist halt wann wird es genügend masken geben dass man eine masken pflicht in der öffentlichkeit anordnen kann und ich glaube dass,
die aufhebung der wesentlichen doktoren maßnahmen erst dann erfolgen wird also was vermutlich dann keine ahnung mitte ende mai oder sowas ist.
Jetzt haben wir vierzehnten april eigentlich waren ja die maßnahmen erstmal bis zum neunzehnten april man müsste jetzt eigentlich fast noch mal so auf den news gerade schauen ob nicht während wir hier sprechen schon wieder neue fakten geschaffen worden sind.
Ne die werden es morgen schaffen also morgen soll die kabinettssitzung sein die bildungsminister haben sich heute vertagt.
Hier steht schon ministerpräsidenten bremsen erwartungen an schnelle lockerungen.
Also wie gesagt also meine also meine vermutung ist dass der eigentliche,
trigger-points wo sie sagen okay wir können jetzt irgendwie tatsächlich wirklich mal lockerungen irgendwie für irgendwie sommer einzelhandel und so weiter und autoverkauf machen wird
die verfügbarkeit dass sie vielleicht nicht eine verfügbarkeit von genügend masken sein und zwar so dass sie die halt einfach im zweifel verteilen also wo sie halt irgendwie sagen okay,
an jedem öffentlichen ort gibt es halt einfach einen masken spender.
Ja aber der rest der welt der fährt nicht hoch.
Ich glaube es wird in jedem land so ähnlich sein dass also die irgendwann also wenn die halt durch den sommer durch den ersten doktors durch sind also hat den die anzahl der.
Noch rumlaufen infizierten halt irgendwie auf einen erträgliches niveau bringen,
und dann werden sie halt irgendwie masken machen und dann ist halt die frage ob ihr geld recht hat oder nicht oder so also was war da die die letzte aussage der meinte sie hätten irgendwie einen stoff der okay wäre oder.
Nein seine aussage war es gibt,
es gibt mehrere kandidaten so sie verfolgen also jetzt muss man dazu sagen ist ja mit seiner foundation schon lange in diesem ganzen an die virus business malaria bekämpfen etcetera pandemien
hat ja jetzt was ja auch allgemein bekannt ist zwanzigfuffzehn diesen schönen vortrag gehalten mit hier nix pandemien coming ja.
Peter prepaid und hat natürlich dann keiner gemacht jetzt steht er da als der große prophet da auf der einen seite auf der anderen seite ist natürlich auch
im zentrum irgendjemand hat geschrieben bill gates ist jetzt so den george soros der der viren verschwörer verschwörung.
Ja so weil sich jetzt alles irgendwie also auf ihn bezieht aber was er da gemacht hat ist es überhaupt lustig ne also er begeht die geht's foundation gibt ja mehr geld an die world health organisation.
An konkret da unterstützung finanzieller unterstützung als die usa derzeit.
Und er hat halt jetzt auch kohle rausgehauen hat ja genug um sieben fabriken zu bauen.
Sieben fabriken die alle potenziell ein impfstoff herstellen können sieben weil es sieben verschiedene,
ansätze technische ansätze gibt wie ein solcher virus impfstoff funktionieren könnte und man weiß halt derzeit noch nicht welcher von denen am ende erfolgreich sein wird.
Nur zu dem zeitpunkt wo man das rausgefunden hat wenn man dann erst anfängt die entsprechende industrielle kapazität zur produktion aufzubauen,
hätte man halt schon wieder ein halbes jahr oder länger länger verloren um um sozusagen von vornherein da die den kürzesten möglichen zeitpunkt zu erreichen hat einfach gesagt dann bauen wir halt einfach alle.
Wird man sicherlich für irgendwas anderes auch noch gebrauchen können aber dann dann hat man auf jeden fall schon mal zumindest für den einen hit wenn sie denn gibt
hat man dann die entsprechende kapazität je nachdem was für ein virus im stoff hier gefunden wird.
Also welche technik sozusagen konkret zum einsatz kommen muss wird die produktion leichter fallen oder nicht es gibt
verschiedene methoden und will da ist jetzt auch eine dabei dann bin ich jetzt nicht so drin da kann ich sie sehr viel zu sagen aber soweit ich es verstanden habe irgendso eine ehrenamt basierte
methode die sich wohl extrem schnell produzieren ließe ja also,
man also sehr schnell sehr hohe zahlen erzeugen könnte und wenn's halt irgendwas anderes ist was funktioniert dann wird's halt unter umständen nicht so schnell geht aber damit halt überhaupt erstmal stattfindet
fährt er eben sieben gleisige und es ist natürlich wirklich bemerkenswert ist eigentlich das was man sich halt von ja von der welt und von zumindest
der us-regierung versprochen hätte,
ja und dann muss man halt schauen ob es klappt so und er meinte halt naja so zwölf bis achtzehn monate wird es aber schon dauern können und das ist natürlich eine menge zeit die man dann eben mit masken mit abstand halten mit
nicht mehr hände schütteln etcetera verbringen muss also das ist halt schon so dass wir uns wirklich gedanken machen müssen wie wir das eigentlich auch kulturell.
Schaffen wollen.
Ja gut ich meine hände schütteln habe ich schon seit januar nicht mehr gemacht.
Ja da das kann ja auch noch am ehesten drauf verzichten.
So das hat ich finde halt irgendwie so eine so eine leichte verbeugung ist eigentlich auch ganz schön das ist vollkommen in ordnung und allerdings.
Also ich glaube so hat sowas kulturell am härtesten sein wird es wenn die länder einander und ihren maßnahmen halt nicht vertrauen.
Wenn's halt quasi kein.
International anerkannten goldstandard für zum beispiel reporting von cases gibt die test regime und so weiter was dazu führt dass länder wieder einander vertrauen können weil wenn das nicht passiert dann heißt es dass jedes überschreiten einer internationalen grenze noch.
Auf absehbaren einen jahr oder länger halt zwei wochen quarantäne oder drei wochen quarantäne bedeutet,
und das ist halt so ein bisschen so wie wie früher zu bestzeiten oder zu cholera zeiten,
der internationale verkehr war also wenn du halt so alte reiseberichte liest so ja und dann laden wir wieder vier wochen irgendwie auf irgendwie der rede irgendwie in quarantäne bevor sie uns irgendwie in den hafen gelassen haben.
Wir lagern formaler glasklar und hatten die pest an bord.
Genau genauso.
Vielleicht so zum
zum schluss noch mal ein blick auf so so ein so ein nebenkriegsschauplatz der immer das potenzial hat auch noch einmal alles enorm zu verschlimmern kennst du das ja auch so ein bisschen diese ganze,
verschwörungstheoretiker unsinn rinde menschen so also man tritt sie sicher heute auch schnell ein.
Also ich glaube dass der was wir da sehen ist.
Dass die leute schon total am limit sind mental ne die suchen halt nach irgendeiner erklärung und ich meine diese nummer jetzt dass da halt irgendwie mobilfunk basisstation abgebrannt werden.
Weil irgendwie irgendjemand auf die idee gekommen ist das vielleicht irgendwie mit dem corona virus irgendwie zu tun haben könnte.
Was auch gar nicht ausgerollt ist.
Ja genau also es gibt quasi keine basisstation wo es welche gibt es meistens dann irgendwie wlan fünf gigahertz stationen die werden trotzdem abgebrannt.
Es ist halt so eine so eine.
Also so ein hinweis darauf wie sehr am limit die leute sind also das halt einfach irgendeine bullshit erklärung.
Solange sie irgendeine erklärung dass die halbwegs kurrente ist halt irgendwie rangezogen und genommen wird um irgendwie,
wieder eine fähigkeit zur selbstwirksamkeit zu kriegen sondern so nach dem motto ich kann konkret was gegen dieses unsichtbare virus tun und nicht nur halt irgendwie nicht hände schütteln und maske tragen sondern ich kann irgendwie an der quelle verbrennen so also so diese
diese diese art zu denken so und dann kommt er zu natürlich so dass die wissenschaft befindet sich ja gerade in so einem.
Notfall modus weil sie ja jetzt liefern muss also normalerweise hat wissenschaftler zeit so normalerweise hat wissenschaftler den
den luxus zu sagen so okay wir gucken uns an dann machen wir eine pirouette study dann machen wir's irgendwie nochmal david und wenn's dann irgendwie funktioniert so dann irgendwie kommt in die zulassung und dann fünf jahre später haben wir dann medikament sonne und jetzt sind wir an dem punkt wo.
Jede studie die neu irgendwie ansatzweise plausibel ist sofort irgendwie als strafe publish wird so und in allen möglichen bereichen so sei es jetzt irgendwie von helfen masken helfen masken nicht.
Dann diese diese ganze frage halt irgendwie mit der mit der also mit diesem medikament das war so eine komplexe medizinische frage ist.
Wo es ja durchaus auch von den den physiologischen mechanismen
hinweise darauf gibt dass dieses medikament tatsächlich dabei helfen kann die fähigkeit sauerstoffaufnahme zu verbessern wenn du halt korona infektion hast aber es sind halt nur ein medikament ist was von dem man schon weiß dass es
durchaus nicht wenige nebenwirkungen hat was dann aber durch trump zusammen,
politikum gehypt wird so was dann dazu führt dass jede studie die sich dieses medikament auch nur so ansatzweise anguckt.
Sofort hart im fokus steht und dann irgendwie wieder von irgendwie den den trump an als ja und sie haben das unterdrückt irgendwie um den virus stärker zu verbreiten und so und dann hast du leute die irgendwie,
aus dem
aquariums bedarf nehmen in ihrer panik und dann daran verrecken was dann wiederum dazu führt dass die anderen in seinem trump hat gesagt deswegen ist chirurgin sowieso bullshit,
also sozusagen es gibt ja nur noch die extrem es gibt ja keinen abgewogenen keine,
okay ist ein medikament was wahrscheinlich wirksam ist unter bestimmten bedingungen nämlich wenn man halt irgendwie bis zum richtigen zeitpunkt anwendet.
Bei den richtigen patienten in der richtigen dosis unter medizinischer beobachtung.
Und nicht ein kein wundermittel aber eben auch keinen keinen bullshit so ne sondern es hat ein medikament mit irgendwie bestimmten anwendungsbeobachtungen,
dass diese abgewogen halt halt weggeht und das halt irgendwie auch diese dieses denken in absoluten halt jetzt gerade nicht hilft sondern sein muss ok,
die informationslage ändert sich jeden tag wenn du es gibt auch wenige anhaltspunkte dafür ob irgendwas wirklich.
Komplett falsch ist oder nicht weil wir wissen halt vieles noch nicht ne.
Führt dann halt aber dazu dass halt viele sachen die offensichtlich komplett falsch sind wie zum beispiel und korona trotzdem dann halt so ein publikum findet und das hat die leute halt einfach irgendwas versuchen zu glauben so.
Ich bin mir grade noch nicht so ganz sicher ob es sich dabei auch um um aktive einflussnahme operation handelt so also weil.
Du weißt du hast du verschwörungstheorie über verschwörungstheorien.
Ich bin glaube tatsächlich eher dass es sich eher um.
Noch grade so mehr um zufälle handelt also um sachen wo irgendjemand eine blöde idee hatte dann youtube wieder daraus gemacht hat was dann auch auf facebook wie real ging und dann war die sache in der welt so.
Na und man macht halt auch geld damit weil es halt aufmerksamkeit erzeugt und aufmerksamkeit hat einfach eine währung für sich ist.
Klar also also der grund warum ich,
gerade annehme dass es halt nicht irgendwelche staaten sind die halt irgendwie aktiv da spielen ist weil dir also die russen zum beispiel nehmen müssen ja würden ja auch riskieren dass der bullshit dann halt auch zu ihnen rübergeschwappt die genau dasselbe problem dann haben
weil die sind ja auch bestandteil der des internets so das heißt also der das risiko halt irgendwie mit so sag mal so gedanken viren zu spielen die dann halt entweder zu führen dass die leute rational verhalten,
globalisiert sich ja auch nannte das hat so ein so ein bisschen so eine weswegen es wahrscheinlich momentan nicht so ist dass da aktiv,
einzelne akteure unterwegs sind aber ausschließen kann man es natürlich nicht.
Hallo
ja und ich meine man hat ja nun auch gesehen bei den politikern der meine trump ist ja auch nur ein beispiel gibt ja da noch ein paar andere vögel die genauso auf dieser welle reiten ich sage nur bolsonaro dein brasilien der auch alles irgendwie abstreitet und
ja ist gleich noch gleich diese verrückte philippinen philippinen theater.
Ja also die ja auch ihre länder dann wie es aussieht auch wirklich,
geradewegs in den ruin führen mit mit dieser nummer also.
In meinem nie enden wollenden versuch irgendwie auch noch mal was positives aus der ganzen zeit herauszuziehen.
Ich sehe halt schon also das mache ich natürlich jetzt an deutschland fest ne so
klar es gibt so diese ganzen ausgeflippten und diese ganz verschwörungstheoretiker die sich ja dann auch gleich zu einer demo hier getroffen haben und der polizei aufgelöst worden also jetzt die ganzen.
Merkwürdigen menschen andererseits habe ich aber auch den eindruck dass sich die gesellschaft halt dann auch jetzt mal hinter der wissenschaft versammelt.
Also wissenschaft war ja nun lange zeit kein thema
in dieser ganzen klimadiskussion liefen die so ein bisschen mit und so und ja müsste man sich ja eigentlich mal anhören und so weiter aber ich kaufe mir jetzt dann doch mal ein neues auto flieg mal für zwei tage in urlaub.
Das.
Diese botschaft ist ja nicht so richtig angekommen diese wertschätzung für für das system ist ja nicht und dann haben wir dann diesen absurden fall das jetzt so einerseits ein podcast,
und andererseits dann auch noch so ein nerd podcast auf einmal so zum zum zum täglichen verkündungsblatt moment.
Des wie geht's uns denn heute wird die visite wird gemacht dem land,
in dem dann der herr doktor kommt und man sagt wie es ist,
das finde ich eigentlich ganz ganz geil irgendwo nicht nicht weil es jetzt podcast das auch aber.
Einfach dass das dass das sozusagen bis jetzt auch nicht überhöhen und er mag das ja auch selber nicht ne aber es hat hat dann sozusagen schon wieder so ein bisschen was.
Was was leid soll so so so eine gewisse leitkultur in der in der auseinandersetzung über alles also man man findet
darüber schneller wieder so ein konsens so ein bisschen so die
die tagesschau dass er einfach gesagt wird so ja okay die dinge können so oder so sein das weiß man das weiß man nicht das ist es bestimmt nicht etcetera und es muss nicht alles stimmen und es kann sich bei ihm auch ändern aber es es ist zumindest geleitet von so einem
rationalen denken was auf evidenz basiert und das das finde ich eigentlich sehr erfrischend.
Naja was was mich da halt so ein bisschen daran stört ist dass es halt schon bei vielen leuten dann halt so ein so ein.
So ein dogma charakter hat also zwar irgendwie zeitlich begrenzt so ne also nämlich irgendwie draußen hat heute gesagt deswegen ist das jetzt irgendwie grade du kannst halt keine andere meinung haben weil draußen hat gesagt,
und dann muss ich halt leider zu sagen so entschuldigung irgendwie euer heilige hat irgendwie vor nicht allzu langer zeit gesagt dass wir irgendwie keine masken aufsetzen sollen ja so wo,
zudem und zwar aus taktischen gründen.
Nicht aus medizinischen und wissenschaftlichen gründen sondern es taktischen gründen nämlich das irgendwie einfach nicht genug masken da waren so und was ich persönlich für einen,
massiven fehler und auch einem also zumindest für mich eine massive einschränkungen der glaubwürdigkeit von dem was er da sagt beinhaltet weil wenn ich jetzt,
daraus folgern muss okay nicht alles was der sagt ist irgendwie seine meinung als wissenschaftler sondern er befindet sich da halt in dem blöden zwiespalt dass er halt so viel aufmerksamkeit hat und so viel glaubwürdigkeit hat dass er halt politisch taktisch
agieren muss dann ja dann braucht ihr auch nicht gucken weißt du das dann halt irgendwie tagesschau gucken so das ist also zumindest für mich persönlich so dann dann ist das halt so ein,
ein anderer akteur der halt irgendwie einen weißen kittel anhat so und dann gehe ich halt lieber selber los und diese studien da hab ich dann halt irgendwie mehr von so
weil ich kann verstehen dass er diesen bedarf nach so einer verkündigung gibt also das hat irgendwie die leute halt quasi einen jemand haben wollen in die heilige medizin messe liest jeden tag so dass also
christiane weitere alternativlos irgendwie es gibt
den tag willst struktur so das ist natürlich richtig ne also so halt der tägliche trasse hat halt irgendwie den den sozusagen sind für so ein element von einen punkt den man am tag abhalten abhaken kann
und dadurch hat es natürlich seinen wert aber zwar setze mal die.
Die meinungsbildung über zum beispiel die wirksamkeit von maßnahmen oder auch die wirksamkeit von medikamenten und so weiter angeht lese ich dann doch lieber selber.
Klar ich sag nicht alles ist alles ist die wahrheit aber es hat es hat den diskurs dahingehend verändert.
Dass man eben über wie du es ja jetzt auch machst so naja.
Die studie gucke ich mir lieber mal selber an und also es gibt sozusagen auseinandersetzung aber alles in einem wissenschaftsbasierten,
modus so also man will erkenntnisse haben man will beweise haben man will beläge haben man will diesen diskurs haben das ist schon sehr interessant.
Das ist halt aber auch genau das das gegen also der gegenentwurf zu dieser,
sag mal wissenschafts- endlichkeit die sich jetzt da gerade so aus dieser impfgegner,
ecke manifestiert also die hat so ein und ich glaube das hat wird halt auch ein wesentlicher teil der spaltung der gesellschaft sein die gab's ja schon vorher wo halt so diese er reichsbürgerin er,
den sag mal so eher flat zu geneigten.
Treppenteile die halt irgendwie irgendwann ja mal so als nein die angefangen haben so wo halt irgendwie also man hat so diese progression halt ja sehen kann von berechtigten fragen über dinge die.
Nicht erklärt worden oder die auch einfach geheim gehalten worden.
Hinzu alles was irgendwie gesagt was ist falsch es sei denn irgendein crack auf youtube erzählt es mir,
so diese diese diese progression hat ja,
mehrere männer in ihre logische fortsetzung gefunden an dem was wir jetzt gerade halt irgendwie sehen so so halt einfach die sag mal so.
So mehr so wunderheilmittel irgendwie story geschichten plötzlich halt irgendwie wichtig werden uns dann halt aber auch schwierig machen.
Die von tatsächlichen sachen die wirksam sind und die einfach machbar sind,
zu unterscheiden also ein beispiel zum beispiel es gibt halt relativ gute evidenz dafür auch mit studie und allem drum und dran dass es möglich ist teil des immunsystems die von corona virus.
Unterdrückt werden und die halt auch dazu führen dass wir die die verläufe so schwer sind dass man die durch wechsel bäder also durch heißes baden und kaltes duschen.
Effektiv aufbauen und verstärken kann,
es ist eine relativ einfache sache so das ist halt so wie man halt irgendwie bei normaler erkältung hast hast du irgendwie heiß baden und dann möglichst heiß mit vielen decken ins bett und und die erkältung aus schwitzen.
Was halt irgendwie so unter diese diese ganze hausmittel geschichte fällt so jetzt haben sie mittlerweile herausgefunden wieso das eigentlich funktioniert,
warum also was der wirkungsmechanismen gibt hat studien indem man sehen kann an der aktivierung von komponenten des immunsystems wieso das tatsächlich funktioniert,
dass es tatsächlich für corona auch funktioniert und die wird dann aber trotzdem von leuten die eigentlich halt eher so wissenschaftlich orientiert sind als zu einfach,
getan also die dann halt sagen so ja aber
das ist doch so eine großmutter irgendwie stories und irgendwie so einfach kann es doch nicht sein und wir brauchen doch irgendwas mit immun modellierung faktor sowieso den wir als tablette oder als spritze kriegen sondern das ist halt so eine so eine.
Genau da hat einen klaren kopf zu behalten einfach zu gucken.
Gibt es studien was eigentlich studien sind die studien blau sibel kann ich selber ausprobieren das ist für mich auch immer so ein wichtiger punkt so kann ich tatsächlich irgendwie ist es halt von der sache die ich einfach probieren kann und wenn's halt irgendwie keinen großen schaden,
geben kann was er da schon passieren dann mache ich's halt.
Und probiere es einfach aus oder gucke halt irgendwie ob ich freunde habe die sowieso schon ihr leben lang kaltduscher sind sind die starke oder weniger stark betroffen ist halt
gibt mir zumindest die möglichkeit mir eine meinung dazu zu bilden die irgendwie jetzt nicht völlig irgendwie abseitig ist so.
Aber dann hast du halt auch wieder leute die halt dann da irgendwelche musical auf youtube versuchen zu verkaufen insofern ist da,
effektiv wahrscheinlich lebensrettend das irgendwie youtube und facebook und twitter und so gesagt haben okay jeder der halt versucht da hat irgendeiner corona kurz zu verkaufen wird halt erstmal gebannt so auch wenn's halt eine krasse zensurmaßnahme ist,
unter normalen umständen halt nicht zu rechtfertigen wäre sondern es sind halt diese blöden abwägung die wir jetzt gerade an allen möglichen stellen machen müssen so.
Ja die welt ist auf jeden fall ordentlich ins bin gekommen so und das
eine ganze menge böse auswirkungen haben ich blicke gerade mal hier so auf die offizielle
verkündigungstafeln zwei millionen konform infizierte weltweit ja ja das bedeutet allerdings dass dieser virus sich schon sehr viel weiter.
Verbreitet hat das wird noch eine weile so weitergehen.
Was haben wir jetzt in deutschland hundertdreißigtausend.
Ja hundertdreißigtausend.
Wir wollen jetzt die zahlen jetzt wird's wahrscheinlich noch ein osterloh geben beim reporting ne.
Ich habe auch schon jemanden nachrechnen sehen kann ich jetzt gerade nur so begrenzt wiedergeben aber in frankreich sind natürlich also weiße zahl aus frankreich müsste man mal aus allen anderen ländern holen dadurch dass jetzt auch keiner mehr auto fährt.
Gab's irgendwie auch einen rückgang an verkehrstoten in in der größenordnung von irgendwie siebenunddreißig prozent.
Und da diese ja gar nicht so wenig sind.
Das stimmt ja.
Teilweise davon reden dass jetzt etwas zynisch so das halt eigentlich so unterm strich so viele leute.
Kompensatorische.
Genauso viele leute wie jetzt neunzehn sterben auf der anderen seite gerade nicht gestorben sind weil sie nicht mit dem auto durch die gegend gefahren sind.
Na so ich weiß nicht am wochenende war irgendwie die anzahl der irgendwie zweirädrigen potentiellen organspender schon relativ groß auf den straßen.
Ja ja das war dem oder dem guten wetter und den freien straßen geschuldet ne.
Genau also die motorradfahrer waren da schon doch irgendwie klägliche zahl unterwegs.
Die bleibt konstant sozusagen den motorradfahrer bleiben konstant immerhin endlich eine konstante in dieser welt die aus den angeln gehoben.
Gut frank ich denke,
das reicht erstmal hier so als als blick in die welt vielleicht wenn man mal eine neue erkenntnislage haben die dinge sich nur noch so ein bisschen weiterentwickelt haben kann man das ja ganz gerne nochmal wiederholen oder an anschluss daran finden.
Ja insofern vielen dank.
Und danke auch an alle anderen die hier wieder zugeschaltet haben als nächstes gibts da mal wieder bisschen zahlen streicheln mit.
Pabel das machen wir dann morgen.